speaker at this point what are the
biggest sticking points in the
negotiation and the president he said
that he's willing to cut spending but he
also wants to raise revenue as well are
you willing to talk about that no
um just to be clear why when you talk
about raising revenue if you look at the
50-year average of America how much
money have we brought in by Revenue that
would be roughly about 17 percent of GDP
right now we're bringing almost 20
percent of GDP in in Revenue now how
many times has that happened in modern
history only twice in 1944 and in 2000
so you're bringing in more money and a
higher percentage than any other time
now so why are we in such a problem the
expenditures the amount of money
government spends so on a 50-year
average government normally spends about
21 percent of GDP right now with 22
after the Democrats took over there are
over 24 percent of GDP so the problem is
it's not Revenue the problem is spending
so if you want to know where our
differences have been it's always been
the same place I simply believe like any
household like any business like any
state government when you're this far
out of whack you have to to spend less
than you spent last year that's why we
talk about that going back to where we
spent just five months ago put a cap in
there grow the economy pull back money
that hasn't been spent like coveted
funds that have sat there for two years
who thinks you should do that save the
taxpayer money grow the economy by
cutting red tape letting us build things
again in America so these are just a
fewer things the other thing is how do
we get people back into the workforce
right so we're only talking about in
work requirements Able Body people who
have no dependence
should we borrow money from China to pay
people who are able-bodied with no
dependence to sit on the couch I don't
think so because we have found every
study it takes people
off poverty rolls and puts them into
jobs it gives them a sense of worth
they're able to buy a house they're able
to send their kids to college it's a
very positive American thing yes
anything to prepare for the potential of
default there are a lot of people
worried about what could happen to their
jobs their savings and so forth to
Americans need to get ready for that no
no no no no no because the Republicans
had passed a bill that raised the debt
scene that's sitting in the Senate you
always have the ability to move that
there's always opportunities
two questions one how would you describe
the tone of the conversation tonight
between you and the president I think
the tone tonight was better than any
other time we've had discussions I'll
have um chairman Patrick McHenry come up
and talk a little bit about as well but
I felt it was
productive because look we both know
we've walked through this for a long
time where our differences we're
explaining them we're we're giving a
give and take of what we think would be
best for moving the country forward we
still will have some philosophical
differences but I felt it was productive
in that manner in the manner which we
produced and I think we were able to
really focus on the areas this
difference Patrick here has been in the
meetings with the White House staff the
whole time and I think the meetings you
have had have been professional and
productive too we've had a variety of
meetings at the at our level for the
last uh
at our level since uh Wednesday Tuesday
Wednesday of this past week and then
much longer to get that ready we've had
tough meetings we've had difficult
meetings this meeting was productive it
told us as the negotiating team a little
more of the details we need to to get to
a package a package that can pass
Congress but to hear the speaker and the
president uh air their views directly
with one another no acrimony but it was
productive and it was a meaningful
discussion and helpful to us getting a
construct that can protect everyone's
equities
but are you confident that you can get a
deal with enough time left to prevent
Americans from feeling the economic
look the thing I want to tell America I
never wanted to be here I never I do not
like the idea that you govern by chaos
you governed by a deadline
so all the way back in January I
requested meetings with the president
after I won speaker only on this issue
we always knew this issue was coming
February 1st I got that meeting and I
sat with the president I told him Mr
President
we should work together to find where we
could have common ground to raise the
debt ceiling but curve our spending so
we stopped doing this and I told the
president there's only two things
not going to raise taxes
and we're not going to pass a clean debt
soon but for 97 days he said he wouldn't
meet with me and now what the
Republicans went and did in the house we
passed a bill that raised the debt
ceiling
saved his money put us on a trajectory
where we could go to balance
this was long before secretary yellin
told us the deadline was June 1st
because we don't want to govern that way
unfortunately
denying our ability to meet put us in
this situation I believe we can still
get there I believe we can get it done
I always I've watched as work before I
think from this discussion he knows
where we are we had greater explanation
of
he had to be at G7 why our staffs were
meeting we were able to explain where
some positions they have I think that
was a better explanation for both sides
well when you look at spending caps and
think about what we pass in limit save
growth we don't say each year we have
government growing by one percent
that was an idea by Joe manchin and so
what we look at when you get elected to
congress we decide just like in a
household if you make a hundred dollars
a week you decide your priorities where
you spend that money that's what we
would do once we get the spending caps
are the top line dollar figure of how
much we'll spend now since the Democrats
went into Power they've increased almost
six trillion dollars that brought us
inflation brought us these challenges
but so the president's budget wants to
spend more money than we spent at the
height of covert we shouldn't do that so
it is easy for us to spend it less than
we spent
last year or this year but only in
Washington is that's difficult and
that's our
our defense cuts on the table
no defense when you're sitting the
president was just a G7 talking about
the fear and the challenge of what China
is doing
we watch what's happening in Ukraine
we've watched the amount
of Weaponry we had to provide to Ukraine
we don't want to make America in a
threatening position so no defense
should not be on the table it's a
responsibility I'm a person who believes
in limited government and it is a
responsibility of those to make sure we
have the defense of this nation and that
would be a mistake did the president
sessions
for nine days out is that something that
you're looking at
looking to do something no I'm not going
to wave the three-day rule because we
have the three-day rule for a reason
you lend your
your voice to your elected officials you
want to make sure they have their voice
if you want to move a bill such as this
and I know in past congresses under
speaker Pelosi was different they would
move trillions of dollars in a day and
nobody could read the bill I'm not going
to be afraid of what the agreement comes
in in the end because I would I would
sit that bill down and I would give
everybody 72 hours so everybody knows
what they're voting on the American
public yes is there a drop dead date
where you need to have a deal in order
to get it through the house look I I've
always felt looking back before we
should already be here and I know as I
told you I've never wanted to be here
all of my actions from the day I became
speaker was to try to make sure we
weren't here unfortunately we went 97
days where people said they wouldn't
talk to us we went more than a hundred
days said you couldn't negotiate on this
we're finally at that point had we
started this in February we could have
been done long before the day
tomorrow well we we instructed um
chairman McHenry and others and in the
White House to come back together based
upon our discussions in the room and try
to find where we can get to Common
Ground there
were you here earlier
so I don't want to repeat myself but
in a 50 years of how much money
government has brought in we normally
bring in 17 percent of GDP so we're
bringing in almost 20 percent only two
times in the history modern history of
this country 1944 and 2000 have we ever
brought in this higher percent and it's
more money than ever before so if I ran
my household where I brought in more
money than ever before
but I owe more money than I make in my
entire year
I don't think it's a revenue problem
it's a spending problem it's the same
thing with government because for 50
years in government we normally only
spend 21 percent of GDP but when the
Democrats took over they raised that up
to more than 24 percent we've never
spent this high and it's going to 25. so
if you don't tackle the problems that
have created you're never going to solve
it so the answer to your question again
that asked earlier is no we're not
looking at revenues and if you think to
put some type of taxes in the in would
only hurt our economy for one secondly
we're already in a challenge where they
raise so much inflation based upon their
spending that would be a stupid thing to
do and you really need to tackle the
real problem look
I've always tried to explain to me a
debt ceiling is providing your child a
credit card they hit the limit and year
after year all you did was raise the
limit you did nothing about their
spending and all of a sudden you owe
more on the credit card than you make
the entire year because our debt we owe
more than the size of our economy by 20
percent
so should you just raise the debt limit
again
is it so Arcane to say should we look at
where we're spending if we're spending
higher than we average do in 50 years
should it be Arcane that we pull money
back that we appropriated during covid
but wasn't spent is it odd to show that
in our history when we have work
requirements we help more people get
jobs and that helps Social Security and
Medicare because more people are paying
in is it odd that we say we should be
energy independent so you lower the
price of energy which helps lower
inflation that makes us less dependent
on China
I don't think we're in a weird place
here it's odd that only in Washington
you have to fight so hard to make this a
reality and that's what we're talking
about
I think they want to make a deal but
what we've watched time and again and
why we're in this problem every deal
they want to make in the past only met
they want to make a deal about spending
more money
at the time of spending just spending
more money in America and government is
wrong and you as taxpayers should say
the same thing you as taxpayers if it
doesn't matter if you're Republican or
Democrat it's coming out of your pocket
every new child that was born today just
got a ninety four thousand dollar bill
and they're one day old I think that's
wrong I think we're failing in that
problem and you know what you can blame
both sides for this but that has got to
stop and it's got to end now and this is
what I don't want you to think at the
end of the day the bill that we come up
with is going to solve all this problem
but it's going to be a step to finally
acknowledge our problem and put one step
in the right direction and we're going
to come back the next day and get the
next step Mr Speaker is there any areas
if any did you guys
I think we both agree we want to be able
to come to an agreement we both agree on
the areas
that we know there's disagreement on but
I think it was productive in the
professionalism the honesty with one
another and the desire to fight try to
find Common Grounds
look there's nothing agreed to
everything's being talked about see some
House Republicans say they won't accept
anything less than the house at bill can
you show them well look we passed a
house-backed bill when no one else would
talk to us we know we've got to get
something through the Senate we've got
to get the president to sign so the way
the founders designed this government
you got a house you got a senate
normally if they both pass a bill you go
to conference unfortunately the Senators
never did anything Chuck Schumer never
put a bill on the floor and if you were
able to do that we would be in a
stronger position but we're carrying the
weight and we're discussing that and I
think at the end of the day you're gonna
have to have compromise
well I believe and Patrick could come
back on this as well they're going to
come back together work through the
night and see if the president and I um
look we know the deadline I think the
president and I are going to talk every
day to try to find until we get this
done
extension look I don't think a
short-term extension benefits anybody
we're this where we're at if if it's a
short-term extension I think the country
looks at somehow we failed that we can't
do the job we're supposed to do
I think a lot of people on the other
side are probably looking back and
wishing they they didn't deny talking to
one another for those 97 days I know in
our own household that's not what will
you do even though I disagree with
somebody but we know we've got to work
together
we know you're the president you're the
Senate we're the house we may have
different positions but if we talk
together I think we could find a way to
solve this problem not talking for 97
days have put us in this problem I wish
that never happened you've talked about
capping spending and fiscal year two I
believe the latest proposal
the White House has talked about tapping
it
at three was there any movement on that
specifically have they moved have you
guys moved from your position so the
speaker's been very clear we need to
spend money less money next year than we
did this year there's no gamesmanship
here he's said the same thing in the
room that he said here he's been very
clear we have a position we've passed it
out of the house the president for days
for weeks for months tomato we pass a
product we passed a product we're here
negotiating he sent his team to Capitol
Hill to go negotiate this deal you want
to get into all the details of it but no
details resolved until it's all resolved
there's been any movement are you still
talking about six years I will tell you
there is productive a productive
conversation by the teams that are in
the room and no one's going to agree to
anything until we have a finalized deal
we got very good direction from the
speaker and from the president the
speaker to his team the president to his
team in the same room we're on the same
page where the same set of issues got to
work through it was productive it was on
and the teams in the room have built
some level of relationship and trust
that we can actually get a product that
that is mutually agreeable to these are
tough issues though make no bones about
it a directive to cut spending year over
year is the toughest thing to do in
Washington D.C but that is the speaker's
directive to his negotiating team it is
our expectation to be able to get that
is there one more question I made for
you yes okay
we tell Americans watching us all unfold
you know at home all right this
grandkids and they and they and they see
the debt pile growing by the years
trillion trillion what do you tell them
who worry their kids and grandkids will
ultimately pay the price one day for
them well this is fundamentally what
this discussion is about when you have a
debt ceiling you have to take stock of
the fiscal house you have to take stock
of spending when Democrats are in charge
of the house with the last president
they negotiated for higher spending we
have a republican house and a republican
speaker who've said we have to cut
spending because the next Generation
cannot bear this debt load that is the
fundamental discussion Point here that
we're trying to resolve and is very
sticky very difficult because there's up
and there's down and unfortunately the
middle ground here is something that is
not acceptable to either party and the
one thing I will say look
the individuals the president asked to
negotiate are the most professional I've
ever seen they're they're intelligent
they're professional they're respectful
and I think that has been productive if
we had only been able to be here 97 days
ago we wouldn't be here we'd all be done
did you ever think at the end of the day
that when you get into a negotiation
with both sides that only one side is
going to carry everything no no one
thinks that but I would hope at the end
of the day when you would sit back and
look that the Democrats said they would
never negotiate that'd just be a clean
debt ceiling I think those in America
would say good job you know what it's
not that so when you talk to your
grandchildren what are you going to tell
them
you know what there's hope there's hope
because they finally woke up they got a
spending problem There's Hope because
there's people who are willing to do
something about it but not just do
something about but fight for them so
what I want to tell you the American
people I will not give up on you this
won't solve all the problems but this is
the first step and I'm going to come
back the next day and get the next step
so I would hope that we could get
everybody on both sides out to vote for
it to actually put their partisanship
aside and think of the grandchild think
of that child born today they got a 94
000 Bill how can you sit there and say
oh I'm going to spend more of their
money
let's stop that let's make this economy
stronger let's take care of the debt
that we acquired because we have a
responsibility to pay it and let's stop
doing this by the deadline worrying
whether we're going to make it we'll
make better policy thank you very much
thank you